alala entendre qu vite c'est vrai qu'on
a tendance à se retourner plus
facilement vers ce qui est ternie tous
où se mouche sauf qu'on est en pleine
phase 2 de printemps printemps est
arrivé depuis ce dimanche dimanche
dernier même le soleil qui est au
rendez-vous les fleurs éclosent les
températures sont clémentes et les armes
forcément bourgeonnent l'arrivée de ces
beaux jours qui s'accompagne de
l'augmentation de la quantité de pollen
dans l'air et donc inévitablement des
allergies ça vous parle peut-être gillet
siggers bonjour on parle de ces
allergies avec vous en cette journée ça
concerne combien personnes aujourd'hui
en france on estime aujourd'hui que 20%
de la population française est
allergique au pollen donc c'est ce et
c'est ces petites particules qui se
retrouve donc en suspension dans l'air
et il faut savoir que ce chiffre
augmente chaque année alors c'est dû au
fait qu'il ya de plus en plus de pollen
dans l'air pourquoi et bien c'est en
partie dû au réchauffement climatique au
fait qu'il ya plus de co2 dans l'air et
donc ça va créer ça va provoquer le fait
que plus de plantes vont pousser en
abondance et donc que aussi la durée de
saison pollinique y va aussi s'étendre
par exemple dans le sud de la france
aujourd'hui la saison pollinique comme
ans environ en janvier en général ça
commence avec les cyprès suivi ensuite
des bouleaux et ensuite ça s'étend sur
le reste du territoire alors en france
il faut savoir que la première cause
d'allergies saisonnières ces sont les
acariens suivi que seulement ensuite par
les les les pollens de graminées et
aujourd'hui sur tout le territoire
français on a un grand réseau de
sentinelles avec des scientifiques aux
quatre coins de la france qui vont
vraiment faire des prélèvements pour
savoir exactement quand ces pollens
notamment les pollens de bouleau vont
faire leur apparition ça leur permet
d'annoncer donc des concentrations et 6
et en plus de ça on a un pic de
pollution par exemple en même temps et
bien évidemment ça aggrave les choses
boulo personnellement on n'aime pas du
tout du tout moi ça me parle les cartes
avec ces zones rouges en ce moment on
est en notamment la normandie dans le
rouge qu'est ce qu'une allergie au
pollen concrètement ça se caractérise
alors qu'est ce qui se passe
effectivement et bien les pollens et
vont en fait pénétrer qui sont en
suspension dans l'air vont pénétrer dans
nos voie respiratoire par inhalation
provoquant chez les personnes qui sont
allergiques ce que l'on appelle une
inflammation ou une réaction
d'hypersensibilité c'est à dire que
votre corps votre système immunitaire va
être détectés ces pollens comme étant
des pathogènes et demi et dont on va
commencer à créer ce que l'on appelle
deux de l'histamine essais l'histamine
qui va créer tous les symptômes des
allergies que l'on connaît c'est à dire
des conjonctivites au niveau des yeux
mais aussi un surplus de muqueuses
nasales donc des rhinites et c'est pour
ça qu'on a des yeux larmoyants piquant
des yeux qui gratte
ddd une gorge irritée ou encore qui
démangent ou encore un nez qui coule ou
alors tout à fait l'opposé c'est à dire
qu'il est complètement obstruée mais ça
c'est la forme bénigne il faut savoir
qu'il ya des personnes qui sont
extrêmement sensibles aux symptômes
respiratoires qui sont a déclenché par
les pollens notamment les personnes
asthmatiques ou juste les personnes qui
sont asthmatiques par exemple à l'effort
sont concernés et comme nous l'expliqué
marie à papa yahoo nous excuser moi papa
ianu qui et allergologue et référente au
pot leur haine pollen pauline art yom de
nantes si on a des symptômes il faut
absolument consulter elisabeth parce que
ça peut nous permettre d'enrayer un
processus un peu plus long qui peut nous
mener vers des pathologies un peu plus
chronique
c'est souvent des symptômes qui
paraissent moindre parce qu'il n'ya pas
de sibérie sévérité initial se souvent
le nez qui coule aux yeux qui grattent
donc les gens ne consultent pas
forcément ce qui est une erreur parce
que plus rapidement au vent consulter
mieux on va casser le cycle vicieux
d'une inflammation qui peut s'installer
et on va être aussi dans la prévention
de sur deux sur une des maladies plus
graves comme un asthme allergique à de
trouver le sommeil on fatigue chronique
qui sont de gros soucis de la saint
patrick alors c'est vrai que j'avais
commencé par ça mais les symptômes
peuvent être assez semblables à ceux de
la coved comment est ce qu'on fait la
différence aujourd'hui effectivement
surtout avec l'arrivée du sou vaillant
ba2 qui présente des symptôme peut-être
un petit peu plus léger on a tendance à
confondre les deux notamment à cause de
la rhinite le nez qui coule mais je
dirais qu'en général la différence c'est
que quand il s'agit d'une allergie on a
tendance à ne pas avoir de mots de tête
de fièvre et de courbatures qui sont
plutôt les symptômes du kobe de 19 alors
et puis ça dépend de la leyre j'ai aussi
un faux ça démange beaucoup plus ça a
tendance à gratter vous allez avoir
aussi une toux qui va être un petit peu
plus différente elle va être un peu plus
insistantes et persistante surtout s'il
s'agit du communisme comment se fait le
diagnostic de l'allergie au pollen moi
j'ai un souvenir des petites gouttes
qu'on le dépose sur les courses
hippiques fait ça il faut pas pour le
coup moi relais attend 30 minutes
exactement c'est ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle un bilan allergologique à
lecture immédiate en anglais un prix que
tu as tant l'entente régulièrement qui
consiste à appliquer sur la peau des
extraits en fait de l'allergène et si
vous avez un petit bouton qui apparaît
aussi vous commencez à vous de démo ça
commence à démanger 30 minutes après
bien c'est que vous êtes allergique et
là il va falloir réfléchir à un
traitement alors il y a des sprays pour
le nez pour la gorge des collyres des
corticoïdes des antihistaminiques qui
sont souvent proposés vous avez un
traitement un petit peu plus à long
terme mais qui ne fonctionne pas pour
tout le monde qui est la
désensibilisation en fait c'est un type
d'immunothérapie on va à faible dose sur
plusieurs années mettre votre organisme
en contact avec cet allergène pour que
au fur et à mesure votre organisme
l'acceptent et ne le vois plus comme un
pathogène et demi mais encore une fois
ça ne fonctionne pas pour tout le monde
et autres mènent aussi naturel qui est
qui fonctionne exactement d'abord
l'acupuncture qui est d'ailleurs
reconnue par l'assurance maladie et qui
va être qui est en général très efficace
contre les urticacées mais aussi contre
tous les profs tous les problèmes
respiratoires il est aussi l'homéopathie
notamment quand on essaie de traiter la
rhinite et il y a également les plantes
la phytothérapie certaines plantes
permettent de réduire la fréquence de
ces crises allergiques je pense autant
je pense à l'estragon aussi qui est un
anti allergène la l'huile essentielle de
lavande aussi fait des miracles
notamment pour tout ce qui est lié aux
voies respiratoires mais attention à
comment les utiliser évidemment et il y
à aussi par exemple sureau le vinaigre
il y a beaucoup de choses à aller
chercher dans la phytothérapie il ya
aussi des gestes à adopter au quotidien
pour essayer de mieux supporter vos
allergies par exemple
aérer la maison plutôt en fin de journée
par le matin parce que c'est là où on a
le plus de concentration de pollen dans
l'air porter des lunettes de soleil ça
peut vous aider ou alors encore un
masque ça peut réduire certains
symptômes fermer les fenêtres lorsque
vous tombez le gazon essayer de vous
laver les cheveux aussi le plus possible
parce que le pollen en fait s'accroche
aux cheveux un purificateur d'air peut
être aussi une solution voilà plein
d'astuces merci beaucoup julia cigare ça
peut servir effectivement en cette
période de pollen au niveau merci
beaucoup julia c'était notre chronique
si on va pour